and a medium for Art and Design as
essential as traditional materials like
paints or clay for instance painting
animation and photography are just a
small sample of once non-digital Fields
where many practitioners now incorporate
software tools such as procreate or
storyboard Pro or Adobe Lightroom
and though users are now working with
pixels and vectors instead of paints and
Clay these software tools still capture
many of the interactive advantages as
when working with traditional media so
for instance direct manipulation
interfaces like Adobe Photoshop that let
users draw on a digital canvas means
that they can make concrete visual
changes and then it's easy to
immediately reflect on these visual
changes and a quick and continuous
iterative loop so this process lends
itself well to exploratory workflows
where users don't often have predefined
goals but figure them out through a
series of Explorations and just sort of
like you know messing with the
canvas computational tools bring
additional benefits over purely analog
forms such as you know the ability to
undo
actions and also organize drawing into
layers which lets you both edit
individual Parts such as how I'm going
to change the text to be blue here and
also entire parts of the drawing at once
such as how I'm going to cast this whole
drawing in a soft orange
glow so I would argue that these
software features I just talked about
are ways that users have power and I
think that generally when HCI
researchers talk about the word power
they often mean it in this power two
sense power two which is like the
ability to do something the ability to
get something done tools mediate are
power two for instance Photoshop lets us
undo operations that gives us power and
we wouldn't have that if you you know we
just drew with like pen and paper on a
pen on paper but there's another form of
power that I want to draw attention to
and this is the notion of power over the
relationship between actors right like
parents have power over their kids when
they tell them to go to bed at a certain
time but kids might have power over
their parents when they're refuse to eat
the dinner that they make um for
instance if we consider in this scenario
artists and users to be one group of
actors and the designers developers and
researchers to be another group of
actors here uh then we can think of the
power dynamics involved within the
exchange of these two groups and I would
say that power dynamics again aren't
inherently bad for instance tool
developers create software abstractions
such as layers that you know enable new
forms of creative practice but also with
abstractions comes
constraints and one way that software
developers constraint artists and thus I
would argue unavoidably exert power over
them is through having preset
functionality such as you know things
found in a toolbar or in a menu while
software features are empowering artists
are limited to only the ones that the
engineers of the system made visible and
also available to them
we can see this tradeoff of power two
and power over clearly and you know the
recent fast and popular advancements and
Ai and stable diffusion models and stuff
these models let anyone who can uh enter
a prompt create an image and it only
took 20 seconds to make here but
obviously with a caveat that it takes
like a ton of iteration and prompt
engineering and stuff like that um so
while these models you know have their
fair share of interface and
interactivity issues I would say that
they do give power to generate a bunch
of new images especially for people who
drawing
skills but beyond the technical limits
of a tool another form of power that the
creators of these models have over
artists is through non-consensual use of
their artwork originally you know put
online in their little portfolios but
now have been massively downloaded and
scraped to use as training data as these
uh for these image models so from huge
media companies such as Getty Images to
even small individual artists right like
people are filing lawsuits now against
these companies and I think these actors
are trying to use the law to gain power
back from image generation companies and
I think the law is also one very
tangible way that we can see power
dynamics get challenged codified and
also
enforced so what happens if we want to
break out of this like preset
functionality the things that you know
the engineers of the system have already
given us well one thing that a lot of
professional artists do or at least some
professional artists do is they use
programming um programming enables new
forms of power too such as making
algorith MC or interactive artwork or
extending preset functionality by
creating plugins and add-ons to existing
software programs and also as we'll soon
see in this talk the cultural dominance
of programming and computer science also
means that artists gain power over their
communities because computer science is
so like respected right um they have
more perceived legitimacy and more
perceived
control so this thesis investigates
questions at the intersection of power
and software tool artists in three
different ways um first what we do is we
sort of try to understand the current
use we talked with 13 professional
artists to understand how they currently
use don't use or build their own
software tools and one take away from
this was that we learned that many
artists learn to program to gain various
forms of power so to support that the
second project in this thesis is
basically an interactive debugging
environment that helps artists better
understand and debug their programs to
make art and we do this we try to get
this like empowerment thing going um by
developing features that align with the
existing workflows of artists such as
the ability to quickly react to visual
changes which current general purpose
debugging systems for software Engineers
lack like if you've ever had to use GDB
and one of your CS classes you know how
horrible uh workflow that is lastly this
thesis contributes a um critical and
generative Theory which uses a lens of
power to analyze software tools for
artists a lens of power can help us
understand how technical decisions such
as what kind of abstractions that we
should use or what kind of software
representation we should choose um can
result actually in unequal power
dynamics such uh and this also guides us
towards a new agenda for what we as
researchers and developers of creativity
support tools could possibly do to
actually mitigate these power dynamics
so while all three of these projects
address issues of power to the first and
the last being more qualitative address
issues of power
over so this takes me to the thesis
statement which is that artists can gain
power through software tools that allow
them to retain fine grain aesthetic
control leverage their manual drawing
skills and move between levels of
abstraction Beyond these kinds of Power
too Al lens of power should also
consider the ways developers and
researchers exert power over artists by
creating normative ground so when you
read this you're like wow there are a
lot of words here what do all of these
words mean um right like what does it
mean to be normative ground or like move
between levels of abstraction hopefully
throughout this talk you will now have
an understanding of all these words that
I will then
operationalize okay and also since the
title of this talk is rethinking power
dynamics in software tools for artists
like I wanted to mention how each of
these projects actually rethinks power
dynamics through their research
questions so the first offers a more
in-depth uh investigation around the
tool use of professional artists and one
way it rethinks is that contrary to
novice users we find that forms of
software automation intended to give
power to make things easier or faster
actually hinder professional artists
because they have a lack of control the
second project rethinks how the
debugging process can be more empowering
for artists when debugging tools are
designed to match and leverage their
existing expertise and skills while a
third project um though domain specific
software features may be powerful such
as in the second project the third
project offers a more expansive view of
power beyond the first two projects and
also basically argues that this
alignment with predefined goals is a way
that developers actually exert power
over their users as it live lives leaves
little room for extending or
appropriating the tools in weird way
ways I think appropriating Tools in
weird ways also is a task that is very
integral to Artistic
practices okay so getting started let's
talk about why professional artists use
don't use or build their own software
tools and also how this intersects with
power so to answer these questions we
basically conducted a thematic analysis
of 13 interviews with professional
artists you can see their demographics
here these artists worked across a great
diversity of mediums this is their work
right there's some interactive
installation art some new media art
comics typography oil painting
Etc and from these interviews we
distilled these six
themes three of which the top three I'm
going to talk about
today the First theme is that artists
resist forms of software automation when
it prevents aesthetic control we found
that blackbox software automations and
abstractions intended to help artists by
reducing task time instead hindered
them um when parameters exposed to
artists did not allow for this fine
grain of athetic control artists just
ignored them altogether preferring their
existing manual practices so this here
is an example of a handdrawn blackl
snowflake like it's very cool radio lead
typography thing and the artist Lyn had
to say about it was quote if you try to
set text on a path in a circle it looks
really crappy so I'll never do it but in
an analog format where I can cut and
paste the letters or Draw them to be
there it looks fine maybe it's because
of the program that it was almost taboo
for me to put type in a shape because it
looked terrible in the interface right
so in the context of power this quote
shows that the taboo poor Aesthetics of
a software default actually held power
over Lynn who hesitated from even making
something that looked like it since the
automation prevented the power to make
something that she had the aesthetic
control and like the Aesthetics
of here's another example of resisting
automations um and it's when they assume
one kind of rigid input data format that
artists haven't made their default
artworks in which hinders again like
adaptability and appropriation so in
this example um this is basically a
vinyl cut snowflake sculpture you can
see sort of the original uh design files
on the top left and then like various
fabricated versions of the other photos
and Molly the artist who made this
basically she was having issues because
when she put that design in the vinyl
cutter file it wasn't interpreting her
lines correctly right like it was
basically cutting too much it didn't
interpret the lines with some thickness
so what she did was instead of redoing
her art in a file that the vinyl cutter
could like interpret she actually wrote
her own custom slicing software to then
actually just cut it the way that she
wanted it um because she disliked how
the default algorithm interpreted her
busier curves she wrote her own
algorithm so in the context of power I
would say that this example shows a
clear lack of power too right Molly
could not achieve her goals of cutting
the sculpture and she couldn't modify it
to fit with her existing workflows even
though the algorithm was intended to be
sort of a helpful abstraction right in
most vinyl cutters you just upload a
file and press print and it's great um
but but not when you come in cases of
breakdown like
this so our second theme then is artists
select software constraints when they
fit with their existing workflows and
also build their own constraints when
they don't so what are some examples of
artists building their own constraints
well here's one from the artist fish
McGill I won't read this quote but
basically he wrote a custom processing
script that Fades your Strokes over time
and this was in the context of his class
he saw that his students were super
nervous getting started with drawing so
he was like okay well well if we just
fade your Strokes then you don't see
them in the end and it's fine you can
draw whatever you want right um in the
context of power fish here gave his
students the power to draw without
pressure while also exerting power over
them as they were forced to use the tool
that he built for class but I would say
not necessarily in like a bad or
oppressive
way um here's another example of artists
making their own constraints so this is
from Iran he's also an educator and an
animator and he was noticing in his
animation classes like if you've ever
worked with Adobe premere Pro you know
you have to like edit the timing on the
timeline and drag things very carefully
he noticed that students were doing that
to the point of fatigue so instead he
built this Loom iPad app which you can
tell there's no timeline like switching
the frames is just moving your fingers
so it's a drawing forward process right
um Iran recognized the trade-offs here
like if your tool has a continuous
timeline rather than a frame based one
your focus is on drawing but instead you
can't necessarily have those fine grain
adjustments that you would with
different animation tools so I think
this is a trade-off in terms of the
right levels of
abstraction so these examples of
professional artists building their own
software also fell under our last theme
which is that artists are motivated to
build their own software to gain
power sometimes this manifest as
personal power like the power to create
new interactive automated artifacts such
as these interactive Museum
exhibits and sometimes it's to gain
technical legitimacy and also be able to
influence their communities in this
framework power over for instance Chris
who has made several tools including
this tool to better uh control neopixel
LED lights he said quote all I can do is
shape the conversation for the
professional tools that get made
afterwards right Chris here is realizing
that like as a single artist he doesn't
have the engineering resources as say
like a large tech company that can push
out features but he can put out tools to
the world that shape the conversation
and shape what is being done Molly also
pointed out the privilege role that
software engineering took in the art
World saying quote there's a certain
part of the population that's going to
think you're way cooler if you can code
that thing than if you can draw it out
which is
crazy so in this section we've seen that
artists themselves can also be tool
Builders they write their own software
programs to design constraints and
abstractions that give them the power to
address their own unique needs and also
contrary to the belief that all forms of
algorithmic automations could be helpful
we learned that artists are using tools
and automations made by others when they
can retain fine grained aesthetic
control and have the power to
appropriate them in their
workflows so I urge us to rethink the
positioning of artists in our community
to realize that they can be powerful
technical collaborators because I would
argue that like creativity support tool
researchers artists are motivated to you
know produce novel results and influence
and have power in their communities so
to me this qualitative research shows
that you know beyond initial need
finding or usability methods um common
in human- centered design or even Beyond
particip Ator design uh methods that
engage artists and future decisions
artists who code can also contribute in
deciding low-level engineering
representations and abstractions things
that are often reserved just for you
know the research team or like the
computer science
phds okay well what about artists who
are not yet expert programmers how can
we help every artist be empowered to
understand the code they write and how
the parameters they choose affect their
artwork so this was the motivation
behind the second project which is
called demystify Dynamic brushes where
we sought to build an interactive
programming environment that could
better leverage the existing skills of
visual
artists um and more specifically when I
use the word existing skills I mean like
visual sketching right sketching is very
fast it's a tightly coupled execution
where you react through your hand to the
pen to the page um and as such I would
argue that artists are good at visually
reacting to thinking about and
manipulating concrete media but the
process of writing code to make art is a
very different
process so we can see some of the
differences by analyzing the tools and
interface that artists use so let's say
that the canvas for a digital artwork is
basically a guey rapper around the
artwork itself I've been talking a lot
so here's a question for the audience um
what would you say the canvas for an
artwork made with code
is was there a hand there yes en exactly
the coding environment or the IDE um so
this means instead of working directly
on the canvas directly on the thing that
you're drawing right um and manipulating
concrete artifacts you are instead
manipulating abstract symbols or code
that represents the artwork uh instead
of being able to immediately observe and
reflect on how your actions result in
visual changes the process of
programming and execution are separate
right sometimes it's unclear like which
pixel is caused by which line of code
and instead of allowing for open-ended
Explorations programming is highly
structured I remember taking my first
Java class and you had to write you know
all these classes and stuff before you
could have any hello world or any print
statement so like sometimes you have to
build a lot of scaffolding before you
even see anything on the canvas and then
by that point maybe you have forgotten
like what is happening or like where is
anything so I would say that if the
factors afforded by GUI tools are not
currently afforded by programming tools
how can we design a better canvas such
that facilitates program inspection and
comprehension in a way that's more
empowering to artists in a way that
makes the programming workflow look more
like an artwork
workflow so the hypothesis here was that
instead of debugging by editing lines of
code or slowly stepping through an
execution Trace artists could be more
empowered in the power two sense to
understand their programs if they were
given an environment that number one
leverages their immediate reactions to
visual changes and number two leverages
their existing expertise of working with
concrete media as opposed to abstract
symbols um and when I use the word
empowered here I mean it in the term of
the sense of psychological empowerment
which was coined by Mark Zimmerman in
the 1990s and psychological empowerment
comes with three things number one is
feeling so do we have perceived control
do we have self-efficacy do I feel like
I'm able to debug and make changes on my
code number two is knowing like do I
actually have the concrete Knowledge and
Skills and do I understand what my
action opportunities are to be able to
develop and debug this code and then the
final one is doing like can I actually
take action can I in practice actually
debug and change my code um um we don't
focus on the third aspect of doing
because that is covered by the previous
project that this work builds off of
which is dynamic brushes so the original
Dynamic brushes by Jacobs at all is
basically a tool that's split into an
iPad drawing interface and a desktop
programming interface so on the desktop
you can create these programmatic
brushes and then you can draw with a
stylist on an iPad so here the user has
basically created a radial brush that
mirrors their stroke five times in the
sort of star pattern and also changes
the color to be like a rain
pattern so what is demystified dynamic
brushes um well basically it extends the
original Dynamic brushes environment
with these linked visualizations that
enable artists to explore their code
while drawing for instance these
parameter values and the dust toop
environment these tables of numbers are
just moved directly on the canvas and
visualized um so I'll walk you through
some of its features right now the first
feature is the visual inspector so
basically it's exactly what I just said
it takes the numeric values puts them
right on the canas this and then also
draw some dots there's also this sort of
brush icon inspector that shows you
various parts so you can tell as the uh
stroke jumps up and down the little y
AIS also jumps up and down because it
represents the scale y here this is part
of our working with concrete media
hypothesis instead of looking at symbols
why don't we look at the numbers
directly on the canvas um ddb also has a
direct selection feature which basically
lets artists jump to program State just
by touching a pixel of the artwork
addressing the earlier issue that
sometimes you don't know what line of
code causes which pixel to be drawn um
also part of our concrete media
hypothesis right we're concretely
selecting from the artwork itself and
finally ddb has this looping feature
which lets artists record and play back
their past stylus inputs so basically if
you draw something you can just press
the loop and then you don't have to draw
it anymore the system will immediate
will automatically record your stroke
while you can then go and change the
program um so let's pause a little bit
here to explain what's going on so
before this little line was green but in
looping the artists have dragged a sine
wave to Hue I know it's a little small
so now the instead of having a solid te
teal color the output is rainbow and you
can do this and change any sort of your
program while the system Loops your
inputs uh over and over
again uh and again this is part of the
immediate reaction hypothesis right like
now we're changing we're not focusing
necessarily on lines of code but the
actual visual changes that happen in
your artwork okay here's another quick
looping example this is a mirror brush
the left side mirrors the right side so
I've drawn something on the right side
and now what I'm going to do in real
time is I'm going to change the scale y
to 0.2 it was one so now you can see
that the left side doesn't go as deep
down as the right side again like visual
changes now I'm going to change a square
wave to the scale y so now you can see
the left side jumps up and down like the
form of a square wave and then in the
top left corner you can see there's a
visualization of that square wave of the
current value
okay so in addition to all these
features we also had these numeric
tables as I mentioned and also a
stepping feature such as common and
traditional software engineering
debuggers which lets you slowly execute
the function line by line so here you
can see we're just stepping through
every brush parameter and then once we
finish stepping it draws like sort of a
little bit of the drawing in the lower
corner so the question was where are
features of visual inspectors direct
selection and looping actually helpful
was our hypothesis that leverag artist
manual skills could Empower them to
better debug and comprehend programs
correct did they actually increase the
feeling and knowing aspects of
psychological empowerment to answer
these questions we basically conducted
an observational study with five artists
who had no programming experience and we
asked them to modify these three starter
brushes on the left to these three
Target brushes on the right um and then
we had some open-ended brush creation
time so it was a very observational
study um and at a basic level we saw
that yes artists were able to understand
and author their own brush programs
specifically we found that one artists
prefer to debug by using the visual
inspectors and replaying uh and
replaying and looping stylus inputs over
traditional methods like stepping
through an execution trace and I think
this is because it matched their
existing workflows did not require them
to Contex switch out of drawing by
nature of these things being on the iPad
instead of the computer but also like
mentally for instance P4 said of the
numerical inspectors quote this is
helpful but painful I love it but you
have to focus which keeps you which
takes you out of the drawing zone right
it's they're talking about this context
Swit that's
required we also found qualitative
evidence for greater psychological
empowerment um for instance for the
feeling aspect P2 reported a sense of
perceived control in having the visual
features saying quote as we created the
brushes over time I needed to know
exactly what the numbers were an hour
into the session I felt like I was
translating between the world of numbers
and artwork since I could see how the
correspondence was happening right like
that seeing helps them establish a
mental connection um T3 described the
visual inspectors as helping them
develop skills and knowledge to
comprehend how to make a spiral brush
saying I knew that the saw tooth wave
was right since it only went up in One
Direction as I drew just like how the
Spiral goes in One Direction while the
other generators went both up and down
right so it was like the fact that they
had these visual indicators helped them
develop knowledge uh going on they also
said that about the brush indicator I
looked at the rotation Arc to see if it
was full so I could make big enough
changes when it wasn't full that's when
I realized I needed to multiply it the
program itself is coded in degrees so if
you did Sawtooth to rotation it would
just be between 0 and 1° so that's why
you need to multiply it by 360 to get
the full circle and then they saw that
because the circle was not filling up in
the brush stroke
indicator so through demystified Dynamic
brushes we've demonstrated how
programming environments specific to
artists could look supporting workflows
that are exploratory concrete and manual
because we visualized and moved program
information to the canvas to the
execution rather than the programming
environment artists now have the power
to engage with their code without
contact switching from drawing and our
direct selection and looping features
gave artists the power to interact with
their code from the hand rather than
from symbols so I would say that
programming is a powerful tool to make
art and we wanted to make traditional
software debugging workflows closer to
those of manual drawing for the specific
context of
artists okay ddb was an example where
researchers hypothesize researchers I
mean like me and the research team um
hypothesized and tested what the right
features like and what the right levels
of abstraction for some predefined goals
that we wanted to support were I think
it followed an implicit argument in a
lot of CST or creativity support tool
research which is that designing the
appropriate level of abstraction for a
domain specific task or User Group means
that we create empowering interfaces and
I would call this method that of
abstraction alignment but in this last
project by applying a lens of power to
this method I think we can see that
abstraction alignments actually aren't
enough and in fact one way that research
or in fact one way that how researchers
have power over the users of their tools
despite their intentions to
help okay let's back up a bit first and
more closely analyze the abstractions
that we had in ddb okay let's say we
have a ladder of abstraction the top is
highest level abstraction bottom is
lowest level abstraction and let's take
for instance the task of changing a
color of a drawn stroke right at a very
high level abstraction you could do
something you know like chat GPT just
say like make it blue and then the
program will just make it blue for you
um but I would say that a high level of
abstraction does not facilitate learning
right artists need to think through
their code to make relationships between
it and their artwork so that's why in
ddb we chose a lower level of
abstraction which was visually observing
numerical mappings and then like
actually changing the code yourself to
bettery to uh then modify the program
itself but there might also be edge
cases that require lower levels of
abstraction than the one we chose for
instance um our current program works at
in the HSV color space but what if
artists wanted to choose colors in the
RGB color space instead well currently
as ddb is designed they have no way to
do that right they would actually have
to open up our source code and Swift and
like get it and then change everything
to an HSV representation this is
something that they can't currently
do and I think when artists can't access
the right level of abstraction
particularly at times of breakdown or
when working against black boxes they
then move horizontally to other tools in
the ecosystem we can see this with the
vinyl cutter example from the first
project right um Molly could not get the
vinyl cutter to interpret her bezier
curves so she actually moved diagonally
like she moved lower into a new tool to
processing to then write her own custom
slicer before she moved back to the
vinyl cutter to then upload her newly
generated tool path
here so because of their need to
appropriate or even misuse tools for
their own idiosyncratic workflows in
this work we're arguing that beyond the
notion that researchers and Tool
developers should prei a level of
abstraction for artists artists need the
power to move vertically through
different levels of abstraction to suit
their task at hand as well as move
horizontally to interupt with other
tools um and I would say that this is
empowerment in the technical sense
empowerment in the power two sense right
the sense that these HCI researchers
when they wrote this designed principles
for tool to support creative making most
likely May uh meant when they said our
goal is to develop improved software and
user interfaces that Empower users not
only to be more productive but more
Innovative but I think viewing
empowerment solely through these
traditional technical methods misses out
on how tools can do all of these things
but still be disempowering especially in
the power over sense so towards a more
precise understanding of how power to
and power over relationships manifest in
creativity support tools I conducted
interviews with 11 CST practitioners who
were a mix of professional artists tool
designers and also CST researchers and
often an overlap right like as Sean said
I'm a CST researcher but I am also an
artist not a professional one though um
and in contrast to the Thematic analysis
methods we used in the first project
here we used provisional coding
provisional in the sense that we
basically developed and iterated on a
vocabulary to be able to talk about
power with people which is harder than
you think um so then our goal was to
build a theory of power to csts that
could explain existing power dynamics
and give predictive critical and
generative guidance for the design of
Future tools
so like the first project we also
distilled six themes don't know why six
is the magic number here um we touched
on these blue ones of vertical movement
and horizontal movement already so I'm
going to focus on the first two of what
does it actually mean for artists to be
empowered and also this concept of
normative ground that I will finally get
to explain and before I dive into the
ways that artists felt empowered I just
want to make it clear that artists are
not a monolithic group some of them
particularly production artists who had
full-time jobs responding to client work
and stuff Stuff felt empowered in ways
that aligned with the current
conversation in HCI so for instance P1
said the most empowering experiences
were those when they didn't have to
think about the tool and they could just
focus entirely on the drawing so the
tool just faded in the background which
Echoes ideas uh from ubiquo is Computing
and Mark
Weiser P3 felt that they said that they
felt empowered by using the liquefy tool
because uh it let them move entire parts
of their drawing at once without having
to manually redraw something so like how
ddb aligned with exist skills of artists
the liquefy tool was empowering to P3
because it matched with their existing
skills of judging spatial relationships
while also saving them time I would say
that these ex examples align with what
p8 who was a tool designer said was
their main goal when making tools to
quote remove as many obstacles as
possible to enable an efficient
practice but for artists whose creative
practices were not con constrained by
external clients empowerment May meant
not making things more efficiently but
the actual reflective process of
creating art which made the invisible
visible for instance P6 said they felt
empowered when art making intentionally
structured their time towards focusing
on specific objects and memory saying
quote when I draw a picture of something
it's also time I get to spend looking at
it and just thinking about all the
little objects in it just reflecting a
little bit and spending time with that
picture and all the memories I associate
with it I hope I'm more visible now
because the lights went on um and I
think this new okay I guess not and this
new way of see
also extends to getting audiences to see
in the way that the artists wanted to
see right so here's an example from P4
who made a type face by basically
erasing parts of celebrities faces in a
facial recognition training set um that
it says Jeff Bezos if you look closely
enough and P4 said my art directs The
Gaze on the powerful rather than the
marginalized it's trying to
authentically capture my kind of
subjectivity and worldview right for
both P6 and P4 empowerment meant having
a creative practice that not only
revealed something new to themselves
about how they saw the world but also
their ability to share it with others
for others who interact with the art to
adopt their personal viewpoints artists
feel empowered when they can exert power
over their audiences to get them to view
things in a certain way that they would
not have otherwise in fact I would say
in my personal life like that has been
the most meaningful experiences of art
for me when I look at it and then I like
think something differently about the
world okay so if you believe in this
then what does that mean for HCI resurge
right um interfaces in the first wave of
HCI were often designed to make like
office workers more productive at well
scoped tasks that were relatively
predictable um but in contrast to
creative tasks it's kind of hard to
Define and predict the bounds and
requirements of creative work in fact I
would argue that some creative tasks May
by their nature be defined by their
misuse of tools such as the work of P5
who who was a creative coder who said
quote the interesting things are doing
what tools are not designed for right
like appropriation and remixing and
misuse are actually core to their
process and conceptual pieces and can't
necessarily be separated from the kinds
of art that they
make so if creative practices are
unpredictable emergent and messy like
right these are things that make
creativity wonderful but they're also
really hard to computationally support
so that's why earlier I advocated for
movement along the levels of abstraction
as opposed to prescribing where a user
should lie and also letting artists
choose the level of abstraction that
works for them as one step towards
letting them appropriate and misuse
tools towards their idiosyncratic
workflows so now I'm going to introduce
this concept of normative ground that
tries to help explain that when we do
prescribe the level of abstraction of a
creative practice we can also
unintentionally exert power over
creative practitioners we Define a
normative ground as the way a tool
structures its practitioner ideas goals
and intentions shaping how someone
thinks acts and expresses themselves so
if you're thinking to yourself oh wait
this sounds familiar like people have
already talked about this what about
like the Gulf of execution and
evaluation and stuff I think the
emphasis here is actually on the
normative part right technology is
always political and always has the
values of the creators embedded in it so
when people build tools they implicitly
make a statement about what should be
good right what is the way to empower
someone for instance like your phone
autocorrects uh reinforces a belief of
what good English is and this is a way
of exerting power over people by
defining Norms um so let's walk through
some examples of our interviews to show
the ways that normative ground gets
enacted and how a tools Norms can
actually influence practitioners goals
beyond the ways that they can fully
intentionally
control one way we see how tools shape
users how users think is by comparing
Adobe Illustrator to Adobe Photoshop so
both P1 and P3 were used to photoshop
because you know it's more like the
workflow of drawing but they talked
really at length about learning to learn
the language of Illustrator and sort of
think in the program which means
thinking in terms of vectors and Boolean
oper ations as opposed to like loose
brush strokes but once they learn things
such as the uh Pathfinder tool which
lets you do Boolean operations on shapes
and stuff they were like oh man
illustrator is awesome I can't do this
in Photoshop so here was a sense of
having the power to do things that one
program did not allow them because they
then adapted their mental model to the
language of
Illustrator another part of the
normative ground of a tool is its
default Aesthetics so for instance um
artists were considering not just the
features but also the community that
surrounded it P9 said that they had a
DNA Heritage around tools such as paint
tool sigh or clip Studio paint like
things that were used very popular in
anime drawing communities because they
like to fit into that aesthetic and they
like to fit into that Community they had
the power to be part of a community
around an aesthetic style afforded by
the default brushes of these programs on
the flip side P2 talked about their
waning interest in AI art as it became
more mainstream right they were like oh
I'm not super interested in the
aesthetic anymore cuz I see everyone do
it um so just like how the type on a
path snowflake example happened in the
first project the default Aesthetics
with a tool held power over the kinds of
the artists and influen the kinds of art
that people wanted to make or not make
with this and again like if you're a
tool designer and you're making these
tools it's hard to predict this who
knows if your tool is going to be super
mainstream that everyone's like
uninterested in using it right um but
these are things to I think be aware of
so also while the ways tools aish
normative ground is not entirely within
a designer's control I think one way
tool designers do have control is
through how people first use the tool
such as through the documentation so
processing gives many coders the power
to create art it also I would say
constrains them to a particular kind of
symbolic and Abstract aesthetic because
of the nature of like being a code-based
program um so P5 a creative coder
lamented this uniformity saying quote
the interesting stuff in art is peeling
back the layers which reveals getting to
unique styl
sty stylistic variations just following
the docs won't I'm always finding the
tools because they try to strip all of
the process Away by the nature of being
coding based right they were working
within the normative ground of
processing this coding based sort of
default aesthetic normative ground and
challenging this Norm ground was
actually how they defined their creative
practice okay so I think this is the
heart of what tool designers need to
contend with sort of the Paradox of
empowerment here I think the decision to
make certain operations easier with the
tool the fact that the tool makes
creation more accessible to people will
then set a normative default aesthetic
that may actually result in
uninteresting art to some practitioners
it's so like how do you win in this case
right um this is a way tool designers
exert power over their users but also a
chance for artists to create meaningful
work by stepping out of these Norms I
think solely focusing on making
predefined tasks easier or more
expressive doesn't provide a way for
artists to challenge the normative
ground of a tool as this expressivity
will still be within the tool tools to
predefine use cases so again that's why
we recommend tools enabling horizontal
and vertical movement um as this
supports artists and appropriating or
extending tools for their own unique
pract purposes and starts to mitigate
these uneven power dynamics that are
created in any
tool okay so we talked about sort of the
first part let's now talk about the
critical part and actually let's make
sense of some past research and
creativity support tools through a lens
of power for instance there's one Trend
in CST that let users edit a
representation at a higher level of
abstraction so for instance here you're
not animating every individual fish
you're drawing the motion path of all of
the fishes or in Project blink um you
edit text you edit a video through
editing the text transcript like again
these are very powerful features and
they make some tasks more efficient but
I would also say under a lens of power
they limit the kinds of tasks that can
be accomplished right since they can
often computationally not support
reimporting the edits done at a lower
level of back to the higher level
representation for instance with project
blink like if you didn't have text but
you wanted to edit the video like there
was some awkward silence or something
you would have to you know go do that in
premere or whatever but then if you had
to edit more text you can't reimport it
back to project blink or sort of stuck
at this lower
level tools that scaffold novice's
abilities through applying expert
computational constraints such as
helping beginners draw faces by giving
them a photograph that they can trace
after or help people with 3D sculpting
or help people with photography
composition um I think these are great
in that they help users build up skills
so they can produce higher quality
artifacts but in the context of a
normative ground we can also see that
these tools sort of uphold traditional
Notions of what good artifacts should
even look like right they're saying this
is what is like correct or like this is
what it should look like um even when
novices become experts and no longer
need these beginner tools I think the
tools values still implicitly structure
and influence their creative
practices so now that we've seen the
analytical and critical applications of
this Theory how about the constructive
side if I'm a a tool designer what can I
do in this case um and I want to
acknowledge that tool designers can't
control every external Factor affecting
our tools power relationships but what
we can do is control the design and
Engineering decisions and while our call
for supporting values of appropriation
adaptation and composability aren't
necessarily new like here are people who
have said that before I think a lens of
power reveals the logic for why holding
these values is
important we've seen that power
imbalances happen when rigid
abstractions are missing lined with
artist idiosyncratic goals so right what
if we design tools with sort of multiple
API handles or entry points in mind
going back to the ddb example if we
wanted to support things to make it blue
like what if we created a handle that
exposed the parameter mapping so then
users could build their own extension um
and build a speech interface on top if
they wish or in the other direction the
lower Direction a handle that exposes
the function of creating a parameter
mapping so users can then create their
own unique parameter mapping such as
like RGB values beyond the ones preset
in the system and I think while we can
help identify what the most Salient
abstractions to expose in our system are
predicting sites of appropriation almost
seems like an oxymoron right like how
can you predict what people are going to
appropriate so I think another way we
can help mitigate power and balances is
through focusing on building composable
Primitives rather than full endtoend
tools where everything is prescribed for
you so you know what if instead of
deciding on what the right abstraction
is for a tool we focused on discovering
what the right Prim would be what the
right building block would be such that
artists could then build up their own
abstractions in the tool what the right
interruptable data representations are
so artists can easily transfer their
work to other tools to accomplish things
that Euro tool couldn't um the question
here then becomes how do we actually
identify what these like right
Primitives and representations are and I
would like to remind you from the first
project that I think professional
artists who code are well positioned to
answer
this but even if you lack professional
artist collaborators um this project
developed a sort of table of generative
questions to help you think through
aspects of power in tools analytically
critically and also constructively and
this was taken from this generative
theories of interaction paper that I am
very inspired by Wendy McKay is also
giving an HCI seminar talk like I think
in a month too um so for instance in the
question of asking what a good primitive
would be you can ask yourself what is
the smallest or lowest unit of useful
operation in the tool and how can it be
composed together within the tool or
extended to interface with other tools
right like this isn't an answer but but
at least it's a starting
point so I would want to see a future
where our creativity support tools are
less like prototypes to test you know
our hypothesis that X abstraction makes
doing y task Z times faster or to test
the validity of some design principles
that we made but rather where we treat
them as design probes because I think
treating csts as design probes could
teach us new information about the
creative practice itself rather than the
contribution just being the tool itself
um and cases where tools fail might be
more interesting than cases when tools
work what artists do with the pros might
be more interesting than the design of
the tool itself um of course the flip
side then is to shift our values away
from always searching for the next
research paper and just spend time to
actually release and maintain and invest
in the communities that the tool is
supposed to help I think that is also
another way to mitigate power imbalances
here so to summarize this work rethought
empowerment by showing us that what uh
by showing us that removing obstacles or
enabling greater efficiency being
empowered by artistic software tools
means that they support actualizing and
sharing a human perspective on the world
we talked about the unavoidable power
over relationships that tool designers
have over their users due to enacting a
normative ground and potential ways to
mitigate that such as through enabling
vertical and horizontal movement um
instead of prototypes for efficiency I
think I want to see a future where
software tools for artists can also be
probes for
creativity
so now at the end of this talk I've
hopefully offered A New Perspective
around how we are building software for
and with artists returning to my thesis
statement I hope now that we can see
that while these technical technical
considerations of such a such as letting
artists retain fine grain aesthetic
control leverage their manuals drawing
skills and move between levels of
abstraction are great to empower them
it's also important to have an
understanding of the normative ground
that they are working in and the power
over relationships that are present in
tool use
so in terms of future work where I hope
to be conducting more of this research
agenda at Pomona College um I want to do
things such as sorry I want to pursue
the agenda outlined in the last project
such as longitudinally studying how
tools impact power dynamics in artistic
communities by using new methods and
what do I mean by new methods well if we
believe that csts are better served as
creativity probes then this means our
research contributions should shift from
being artifact Centric to interaction
Centric studying things such as how
tools are repurposed by users in the
real world through longitudinal use or
the kinds of aesthetic or social
relationships they open up or how they
do this how they fail to do this and why
I think then this means in addition to
current evaluation methods survey based
ones like the creativity support index
or NASA TLX um we could also draw
inspiration from qualitative methods
from anthropology such as offering thick
descriptions of tool interaction or
valuing participatory Community Building
while I spent a lot of time talking
about power and software Tools in this
presentation one limitation that I never
explicitly addressed is how these tools
intersect with systems of race class
gender ability you know codified social
systems that are explicitly there to
give some groups power over others so I
think research questions here would
include what is the role of creativity
support tools for marginalized people to
respond to the oppressive forces they
endure or what would creativity support
tools to support what even ellich calls
a convivial Society or what David Graber
says is giving voice the voiceless look
like and finally while in the first
project that I argued that artists can
also be researchers I believe the flip
side that researchers can also be
artists and making creativity support
tools can be an artistic practice itself
some of this comes from participating
and shaping culture with research you
know such as supporting artist
residencies in your lab or partnering
with community art centers some of it
comes with making research just more
accessible like Distributing it as a Zen
like I want to make a Zen for this whis
talk in a month
um but the guiding philosophy of this
means that I think the tools that we
build ourselves can intentionally
propose new normative understandings of
the world right like when you're
building something you are setting your
values out in the world so you are
actively shaping that the world that you
want to see and in the process also
revealed to us something about ourselves
not only as researchers but also as
artists so hopefully by now I've at
least partially convinced you of the
value of research that takes creative
practices and creative practitioners
seriously um before we do Applause I
would like to do some acknowledgements
if you came to my actual thesis defense
these are a little different this slide
is the same I would like to thank all
the collaborators that I've had
throughout my PhD they've been so
wonderful both in these projects here
and projects that I haven't shown um
some of them are in the audience right
now and I've learned so much from all of
my collaborators I would love to give a
huge shout out to my committee so the
last time I gave this talk was about
five months ago when it was actually my
PC defense and we took a nice photo so
thank you Sean for being an amazing
adviser to me um I really could not have
done it with all your support thank you
also to James for being a Committee
Member um Manish uh Camille and also
Jennifer Jacobs who I feel like was like
a third adviser to me as well um thank
you to the Stanford HCI group as a whole
I think in the last version of this I
showed specifically like manisha's group
and Shan's group but now we have
everyone um here are some photos from
four different years like I will always
miss dressing up as zootopia characters
and Gates 398 which was my office the
two ski Retreats that did happen and I
like you can see the people changing
between the years uh nice dinners with
Sean's Pizza Oven at his house I really
feel like I learned way more from the
students here um than anyone else really
so yay peer learning um and also thank
you to people from Berkeley who really
got me started on my research so thank
you to be crew which was bjor Hartman's
research group this is a photo from 2015
um so and especially thank you to
Valkyrie Savage the person in the blue
dress who was my original PhD student
Mentor who really took a chance on me um
fun fact was in last year I had a
birthday party at tunnel Toops Park a
new park that opened in the precidio and
Valkyrie was there like I didn't invite
her she was just randomly there and I
was like wow what are the chances
because she lives uh in Denmark cuz she
is a professor at the University of
Copenhagen and also she is giving a
seminar talk in 3 weeks so please go see
valkyrie's talks as well um I didn't
have a slide for this but also thank you
to the people who really helped me with
my teaching such as Christina or Lisa
Yang or like Cynthia uh I feel like
these like part of the reason why I
decided to stay in Academia was because
I love teaching and mentoring so much so
I really would not be here or be in a
faculty position if those people did not
teach me so much about teaching um
because this is a public talk I would
like to show my public friends I think
some of whom are on Zoom with me today
so thank you all my friends for making
my life in the Bay Area such a wonderful
one and filled with such light and
lastly oh I have to click here thank you
to my family um my parents are in the
audience today in the background or in
the back row I'm going to cry because I
thought I could do this talk without
crying um but I love my family so much
and I'm so grateful for them and
everything that they've done for me so
really I could not have done anything
without you um okay so this is a link to
my thesis because I've already graduated
if you want to see any of it written
online um pearl. stanford.edu XF 605
mk27 773 uh thank you happy to take
question comments
[Applause]
disagreement yes
ah I
great talk I guess you pumped on it a
little bit but how is your
perspective on some of these issues
changed since you to talk back in May
and like what's evolved since then yeah
great question great question um if I'm
being honest I I did not really revisit
this talk or any of my research work
since me but I do think one thing that
is continually changing here is the fact
that um I don't know I feel like I'm
trying to see how well this Theory can
generalize as like new advancements come
especially in Ai and stuff right like I
think the lawsuit thing is a little bit
older um and now I feel like there are
things such as like control debt which
are giving artists a little bit more
control I think overall it seems to
stand up but yeah sorry I don't have a
better answer to your
question I think a lot of the like
conversation especially as AI um art
tools have come out have been really
focused on like supporting novices or
supporting people who have never done
art before like how can they be
empowered to do art and I think there's
been some critiques of that and I think
your talk has come way more from the
perspective of how do you support people
who are like existing art practitioners
who have put in time to develop their
skills and are like trying to do more
with it um what do you think the
difference of these perspectives kind of
is especially in how it influences the
type of tools you create and like do you
have I I have some feelings about really
focusing only on supporting novices I I
would believe that you might too um and
kind of what do you think of how that
fits into the power yeah I feel like in
a sense I well I don't know if I want to
make this claim but how I've been
feeling about it is that professionals
have more stakes in it right because
it's like their economic livelihoods are
connected to the kinds of art they make
and the kinds of like art that is
happening in the background and the
kinds of tools that are being released
so I think that's why in a sense like
power might be more pertinent I mean
like for novices it's like oh it's just
a hobby like what is the actual scale of
that impact on my like whole life or
it's like oh I want to do a thing like a
graphic for a presentation and I won't
think of it versus like someone who
spends like multiple hours of every day
like dedicated to Art practice and stuff
so I think that's one thing that I've
been aware of is just sort of the scale
of the power differential in terms of
these two separate kinds of groups um
another thing is that one of the people
that I interviewed here who was a
professional artist um in terms of like
the AI art stuff like a lot of their
things was then trying to really look
under the hood of the technology and
like appropriate it like I think they
tried to make like an nft with a
changing URL or something so it's like
oh this like violates the assumption
that like nfts always have static URLs
um so yeah I do think like even though
the tools are maybe more intended for
novices like there are still
professionals who are using them and
integrating them into their art practice
good
question this person whose name I do not
know
um do you think that these power
dynamics can apply to other Arctic
artistic domains like fashion or music
yeah absolutely um I mainly focused on
visual art in this thesis but I think
that is a great domain for future work
cuz I think like power dynamics just
apply to any area of life um I think
there might be different considerations
for like the domain specific ones for
instance like one big thing here I was
like oh artists react to like visual
changes while like music is not visual
but it is real time and also ephemeral
so I think it would be really
interesting to dive deeper in that and
see like okay for these different
domains or like fashion right there's
the like sustainability part and like
the fast fashion part like what do these
actually mean if we go deeper
yeah sorry for the like
passing um amazing talk uh I was
wondering if you mentioned this a little
bit but um there's both negative and
positive places where people can have
power to and
power over
um and there was like one instance that
you're like well this is power over but
not necessarily in a negative way um I
was just wondering if you have thoughts
on yeah just expand on that um and yeah
it's not necessarily always bad to
yeah I mean just take your PhD program
for example or any like educational
instance right I think teachers have a
lot of power over their students but I
feel like most of the time it's coming
genuinely from like a place of learning
or a place of guiding you and like
having you grow to be the best kind of
person that you want to be so I think
that is one concrete example of like oh
yeah there is a power over relationship
but like it's not necessarily a bad one
of course there are parts that can be
bad about it I'm just wondering in the
theory like do you have um specific
places that you're addressing it cuz I I
mean I think it's a really interesting
discussion and like how do you mitigate
over exerting power or versus like when
when is good going back to the novices
thing I think it's mainly in the context
of csts like tools for novices right
because again like I do think a lot
these tools have power over in terms of
how they structure how you think and
stuff but like they the always like I
feel like the researchers always mean it
from a good place um yeah
thanks
thank you so much this was really lovely
um I have maybe a bit of a speculative
question which is that I think each
three things that you presented here um
like hinged on ideas of like exploration
of direct manipulation of Correspondence
as something that is um like artists
especially um like engag in and working
and exploring what that really means in
context and I'm wondering if the lessons
you've learned here help us like learn
something more about like making
software or programming um in general
right that programming is also this kind
of creative thing I mean we could we
could go speculatively to propose that
like making software is also a form of
deliberate seeing and thinking right it
carries I definitely agree different
right um so like yeah I guess I'm
thinking about like expanding to other
kinds of of computer science like do you
think that we can kind of map these
lessons onto other places or maybe on
the flip side are there there special
concerns that we might want to have in
trying to map like what we've learned
here to other places in computer science
and like should we be cautious maybe
about doing something like this yeah
this is a really great question um it's
also a very big question I think going
back to um this person's question like I
do think there are domain specific
concerns of like the history and the
context of specific things but like
honestly part of I feel like the paper
the last work was like this is just sort
of like my life philosophy and like the
values that I hold so in a way I do want
to apply it to everything that I do um
but I don't like I cautious against like
overgeneralization without like sort of
knowing the context and the history
behind things sorry that wasn't a very
specific answer but yeah great well
let's than Genie for a wonderful
talk
great